hey everyone do you know that the demand
for devops professional has opened in
recent years as more and more companies
adapt Devil's practices to improve their
software development and delivery
processes in addition a server by an
Indian founded the Outsource one of the
most and demand skills among Employers
in 2021 with a 47 year-over-year
increase in job postings related to
devops in the upcoming years there will
be higher demand for devops ingenious
due to the growing usage of those
practices and cloud computing technology
here are some popular opportunities in
devops including devops engineer site
availability engineer release manager
automation engineer Cloud engineer and
many more you can expect to earn a
competitive salary as a devops engineer
the average salary for products engineer
in the United States at Glassdoor is
around 104 917 annually and in India it
is 7 lakhs per annum devops aims to
improve software delivery speed and
quality by automating software delivery
and its instructional management
processes promoting Edge GI development
practices and encouraging
cross-functional teams to work together
so are you ready to advance your
professional career to the next level
taking a step-by-step simply and sports
graduate program in devops in
collaboration with IBM will help you
start your devops journey that will
prepare you for the Turks engineer role
in order to match your skills with
Market demands this devops training
program is designed in collaboration
with Caltech ctme are Cutting Edge
Blended learning combines live online
Dev certification classes with
interactive labs to give you practical
experience this postgraduate program
covers topics including it GitHub Docker
CI CD using Jenkins kubernetes and much
more first kick start your day off
Journey with our Preparatory courses
like Linux training programming
refresher agile sperm Foundation
energize the master the next course
covered in this postgraduate program is
devops certification training for
rapidly expanding domain that closes the
gaps between software developers and
operation experts to learn the dogs
tools and methodologies to succeed in
your upcoming devs practitioner position
next an in-depth explanation of the
ideas behind Chef puppet and ansible is
provided through the stealth training
courses section on configuration
management using ansible and terraform
followed by that we have local certified
associate certification training in this
Dove certification course you will learn
fundamental dopa Technologies like
doperhub Toca compose Docker swamp
Docker file local containers Docker
engine Docker images local network
Docker demon and Docker storage later we
have container orchestrated using
kubernetes the certification course will
assist you in understanding the
fundamental abilities tools and ideas
that are kubernetes administrator must
understand and the final one is the
devops capsule project dedicated mental
sessions teach you how to resolve a
challenge relevant to your industry the
last stage of this built training course
is learning path is a project that will
allow you to Showcase your skills index
to potential employees so what else can
you expect from this program this job
training program will cover skills
selector of methodology continuous
integration depths on cloud deployment
Automation and many more you will also
get hands-on experience with the latest
tools and techniques including terraform
Maven ansible Jenkins Docker junit and
many more this program will call the
industry projects like localizing
Jenkins pipeline deploy angular
applications in local container
branching development model and many
more exciting projects by choosing this
training program you could land a job
with a prestigious company like Dell
Oracle Cisco Amazon Google Infosys and
many more this program has benefited
many aspiring jobs in genius and
professionals who have already enrolled
and earned their certifications you can
check out the positive feedback on the
course tweets the link to which is in
the description box below if you are
looking to pursue a career as a devops
engineer an inquiring skills that will
prepare you for your job consider
enrolling in the Intensive training
program you are thrilled to announce
that we have some amazing what's coming
up you can learn more about this program
by clicking the link in the description
box below I hope the program was
informative and interesting if any
queries regarding letter of
certification training program or need
any help then please feel free to let us
know in the comment section below and
our team of experts will be happy to
resolve all your queries at the earliest
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here